the Joe Rogan experience it's really
cool to see and it's these games
particularly quake they are unbelievably
difficult to master and it's one of the
more fascinating aspects of like video
game play and addiction is the
complexity like when you would watch
like like remember do you remember
Thresh oh yeah wait first is the one
that won my Ferrari violation cool that
guy was the hero back in the day of
early quake play he was just this was it
Kenneth Fong as I was named Dennis ball
dennis fung dennis fung there is there's
thrush and I remember I would watch
demos one of the cool things about quake
was that you could is that as Ferrari
and one of the forces that yeah so that
was I my old turbo 308 no you return bow
charged your Ferraris to which I want to
get to as well which is pretty crazy but
so this guy was like the first real
killer in tennis funk there you go first
real killer in the the quake playing
games and you would be able to watch him
play on demos you play through his eyes
so you would be able to see like how he
does things and move around it was
really cool some of the interesting
things about quake where it wasn't
really so clear when we were designing
it but it is a brutal game especially in
one-on-one where a lot of modern games
are much more approachable where if you
followed a lot of the quake games a lot
of them were just blowouts where you
would get somebody that would take
control the level and they would be
running their pattern denying anyone any
foot in the door and you'd wind up with
these twenty to one blowout games where
there are things that you can do in game
design to make it more approachable
where like if you don't have health
packs where you can keep because in a
game like quake you go in as long as you
come out on top and the fight you've got
this little window to run around and
bring yourself bring your health back up
so even if you're only 5% better
you might win every engagement because
you have enough time to go back get
yourself back up before you wind up rien
gauging where in another game if you
didn't have health that that would
continuously you had the ability to
bring it back up then even if somebody
didn't win if they knocked you down a
whole lot then they might get you the
next time around and scores can be much
more even
I'm licensed quit gameplay winds up
brutal tending towards blowouts and very
frustrating before it did not have the
approach ability for new players where a
lot of more modern games things like
overwatch I can be jumped into a lot
more easily because team play is another
aspect of that where if you've got a
team you could be on the winning team
even if you suck because you might have
really great players that are kind of
covering for you there you can jump in
and have the chance to say hey I won I
am even if you didn't contribute at all
and you might wind up I am you know
doing something you start off being
completely useless and then you slowly
work your way up to being able to
contribute effectively for your team so
I can recognize some of these things now
about ways to make games more
approachable but the the kind of
brutality of quake like there was a it
was a taste that a lot of people really
did like it wasn't so much explicitly
designed for that but it worked out that
way and that's one of the interesting
things as we look at game design today
versus the old days a lot of people fall
into a sort of nostalgia trap about
saying well the games I grew up with
were the greatest games ever and you see
it with music and movies and everything
and I tend to be much more optimistic
about the state of things today where
the amount of effort that goes into the
modern games is extraordinary just the
detail and I all the quality on all the
different levels but there is a little
sense of games are so expensive to make
now sometimes in the hundreds of
millions of dollars that they do have to
be conservative so they have to be
careful to make sure that they've got
something that has a broad mass appeal
and I think that is the the upside of
some of the older games where they might
have a little bit more of a distinct
flavor they weren't sort of focus group
to death in the way than some of the
more modern games can be that's
interesting yeah focus group to death
I'm sure as a problem the the quake blow
outs although that is a thing it's so
fun when you're the person blowing as a
person out that it's worth learning the
maps and that that's that was for people
to understand what we're talking about
quake would have well it has maps and on
those maps like this is where the rocket
launcher is is where the railgun is is
where the health is this is where the
mega armor is and you had to know
where these things were and that they
would regenerate every X amount of
seconds and so you're managing not just
you're fighting but you're also managing
the resources so you're running around
and trying to control the map and trying
to control the mega health and trying to
control where the armor is and don't let
the guy get the railgun don't let the
guy get the rocket launcher and in doing
that it's this incredible game of
strategy as well as like fast twitch
aiming and there's so many factors going
and the Masters would have at times such
that they're just running to where it's
gonna spawn and a half second before
they get there it responds they run over
it it's theirs and it's gone and the
difference between the top level players
is something you see in competitive
games a lot even today is you get the
sense of the big fish in the small pond
you know it's like I am the I totally
beat all of my friends asses and we're
the best I'm the best player anybody's
ever seen in my tiny little area and
then you put them in the big pond I with
some of the professional players and
they just they get nothing you know they
wind up not being able to land a shot
there is that much difference of course
you see that in everything martial arts
where you get by the dojo hero in one
place that then goes in and actually
rolls with professional and just finds
out that they weren't all they thought
they were and there's even more layers
of that in games because you're not so
confined to some of the physical limits
of the human body yeah and the amount of
time you can do it is not confined to
the physical limits of the human body so
there's people have they're playing 10
12 hours a day with their thinking and
sleeping and dreaming in you know
catching people with rail shots in the
middle of the air yeah that sense when
you're obsessive about something how it
does invade your dreams and there have
been a number of times in my career when
I'm learning new things when I'm just
immersed in whether it's a new
programming paradigm a new piece of
technology and I'm working 13 something
hours in a day and I go to sleep and I
have dreams about what I'm working on
that's when I know I'm really deep in
the groove of soaking in this new
information and the Dreaming is my mind
helping synthesize this into a useful
form so I can apply this in the future
and those are some things that I look
back on very very fondly when I've been
that obsessive about something that it's
soaked into my dreams yeah I used to get
that with martial arts when I was
competing I would I would throw kicks in
the middle of the night I would have
liked
dreams or like moving and I'd wake up
like you know and it's like thinking
that I was in the middle of a fight and
I had a real problem when we you know we
have this land room set up here with
quake on it and when we got into it
where my addiction got Rhys parked again
we were playing two three four hours a
day I was starting to have quake dreams
it was really weird like I'd have dreams
that I was going down corners and
dodging rockets and assists
that game is so immersive and it's so
you you get done with it and your heart
is pounding like me and Jamie and and
Geoff would play and then when when it
was over we would all be out of breath
with our heart would be race we'd have
to get up and walk around